so your team saves ahg
from sweden 17 33
try a
slightly
longer variation than then with that
six i played
now i could take f3 and that was
often allowed with
so now we actually have quite a
comfortable position with the very
fast development
so he's probably afraid of vw  4
well i
wonder if you can reach something for her so quickly
and now for example the four
knights b 3 and 11 3
move the
queen again but after actually nothing great
i can also easily
develop here
yes
that's what you get if  you play like
that here I stand again nothing at all
about the creation
yes ok
the seven will hopefully not
really hang
well maybe
the 8 lady
to 7
maybe i5 with the editor 28
well he can be shown like
that he had to come like that the  lady was
able to go the seven meters and so
well do
yes I would have 5 each would be possible but
then it is threatened yes the painter recently said
defeat go ic  h now
wanted to play with the idea if he
now goes after four that goes to the springer
the four have
that springer e2 and in
general here the fuel will also
say of course very actively
would like to
swap well well you can you can try here
first of all
speed up  take and say that you
actually have enough activity here anyway
so maybe even with the springer
so do more often springer g6 draws
springer e5 then it hangs
maybe you’ll get it too
i’m here because i won’t see
it that way
maybe it is  a very good
position
yes you had to reckon with that
may even greener the two now
ok so let's assume thom b8 runner
somewhere already a 2
such a quality
yes
the knights are well cleaned up
and
in the 1901 mark broken